The graphs below
show the test grades
of the students
in Dexter's class.
The first graph shows the
relationship between test
grades and the amount of time
the students spent studying.
So this is study
time on this axis
and this is the test
grade on this axis.
And the second graph
shows the relationship
between test grades
and shoes size.
So shoe size on this
axis and then test grade.
Choose the best description
of the relationship
between the graphs.
So first, before looking
at the explanations,
let's look at the actual graphs.
So this one on the
left right over here,
it looks like there is a
positive linear relationship
right over here.
I could almost fit a line
that would go just like that.
And it makes sense
that there would
be, that the more time
that you spend studying,
the better score
that you would get.
Now for a certain
amount of time studying,
some people might do
better than others,
but it does seem like
there's this relationship.
Here it doesn't
seem like there's
really much of a relationship.
You see the shoe sizes,
for a given shoe size,
some people do not so well
and some people do very well.
Someone with a size 10
and 1/2, it looks like,
someone it looks like
they flunked the exam.
Someone else, looks like
they got A minus or a B plus
on the exam.
And it really would be hard
to somehow fit a line here.
No matter how you draw
a line, these dots
don't seem to form a trend.
So let's see which of
these choices apply.
There's a negative
linear relationship
between study time and score.
No, that's not true.
It looks like there's a
positive linear relationship.
The more you study, the
better your score would be.
A negative linear relationship
would trend downwards
like that.
There is a non-linear
relationship between study time
and score and a negative
linear relationship
between shoe size and score.
Well that doesn't
seem right either.
A non-linear
relationship, it would not
be easy to fit a line to it.
And this one seems like a
line would be very reasonable.
And it doesn't seem like
there's any type of relationship
between shoe size and score.
So I wouldn't pick
this one either.
There's a positive
linear relationship
between study time and score.
That's right.
And no relationship between
shoe size and score.
Well, I'm going to
go with that one.
Both graphs show
positive linear trends
of approximately equal strength.
No, not at all.
This one doesn't show
a linear relationship
of really any strength.